es momento de hablar de economía en
france 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela buenas noches vamos a iniciar
con una noticia estadounidense porque se
desvanecen los planes de joe biden para
aumentar el salario mínimo federal o la
valentina buenas noches pues la cámara
de representantes- discute de este
viernes del paquete de estímulos
propuesto por joe biden por 19 billones
de dólares millones de millones mientras
eso pasa lo que sí es seguro es que una
de las principales propuestas del
mandatario está perdiendo fuerza se
trata del posible aumento del salario
mínimo a 15 dólares por hora de aquí a
2025 eso es un poco más del doble de los
7,25 dólares en los que se ha mantenido
desde 2009 pero hay reglas que lo
impiden y la senadora elizabeth
mcdonough que fue designada como árbitro
no partidista del asunto concluyó que
esto no es viable eso por el enorme
impacto presupuestal que tendría y
porque podría también destruir empleos
y afectar a las empresas de cara a la
recuperación post pandemia
los demócratas no abandonan su idea y
dicen que si es necesario van a
plantearla en un proyecto de ley
separado daniela y un impuesto global a
las grandes tecnológicas toma fuerza en
el seno del g20 y valentina estuvieron
reunidos virtualmente los ministros de
finanzas y banqueros centrales del grupo
de los g20 que es de los países más
poderosos y uno de los temas fue el
impuesto que se quiere aplicar a las
grandes olas gigantes de internet a
través de pues de un nuevo impuesto el
debate ha quedado pospuesto en ocasiones
anteriores porque eeuu se oponía sin
embargo parece que tomara fuerza en la
próxima reunión prevista para julio pues
la nueva administración parece que
finalmente no lo va a apoyar al menos
eso es lo que opina el ministro de
finanzas alemán y escuchamos de la
fiscalidad justa de la economía digital
es más necesaria que nunca es una gran
tarea pero ya hemos recorrido un largo
camino
entonces ahora necesitamos obtener
apoyo para este proceso especialmente de
la nueva secretaria del tesoro janet
yellen por nuestra descripción sé que
ella está lista para ellos danielle
cambiamos de tema cuáles son los más
recientes datos de desempleo en américa
latina' valentina tres países dieron a
conocer sus más recientes de cifras de
desocupación afectadas por supuesto al
alza por la pandemia del hobbit 19 en
colombia el desempleo aumentó al 17 3%
en enero cuando hace un año antes de la
pandemia era del 13% un total de 42
millones de personas en edad de trabajar
están sin empleo en este país en chile
por su parte se estabilizó levemente el
desempleo en el 10 2% entre noviembre y
enero casi tres puntos por encima de lo
que estaba antes de la crisis y
terminamos en brasil donde el trimestre
móvil de septiembre a diciembre registró
una desocupación del 13,9 por ciento
equivalentes a 13,9 millones de personas
sin trabajo
daniela y el éxito de nueva zelanda en
la lucha contra contra la pandemia de
coronavirus
desencadenó un problema inesperado
valentina se trata del aumento
vertiginoso en los precios de la
vivienda impulsado por la escasez en la
oferta y las tasas de interés
históricamente bajas que hacen que haya
más compradores interesados en 2019 una
casa nueva zelanda costaba en promedio
456 mil dólares en 2020 ya valía 544 mil
es decir aumentaron un poco más del 19
por ciento según el instituto de bienes
de raíces el ministro de finanzas de ese
país el durante el blog versión fue
enfático dijo que lo que está sucediendo
no es sostenible y por eso el gobierno
anunció la primera de una serie de
medidas para controlar el fenómeno le
ordenó al banco central que considere el
impacto de los precios de la vivienda
cuando toma decisiones de política
monetaria ellos a su vez están
restringiendo los préstamos para
inversión inmobiliaria valentín manera y
los indicadores económicos bolshói desde
cero mixto el mercado todavía afectado
por un mejor rendimiento de los bonos
del tesoro que hace que ya no quieran
invertir en acciones
las bolsas de europa siguieron esa misma
tendencia con fuertes descensos en
londres parís y madrid y en américa
latina' o una caída de casi 2% en el
cierre de una convulsa semana para la
bolsa de sao paulo
daniela pues muchas gracias por todos
estos datos y a ustedes gracias por
continuar con nosotros aquí hay más en
france 24